how's it going red my name is Brad and
welcome bros to another another pixel
horror this one is actually supposed to
be scary
I know crook man wasn't it wasn't that
scary this is actually made by the same
creators crook man and it's called
paranoia can freeze ha ha you can't read
well you can just let listen to my
soothing voice while I scream it's my
voice bad by the way I totally I've been
sick and I screamed so much at had a
party here in LA this last I've going on
in LA and but that's that's another
story for another game or something I
don't even know what I'm talking about
this game contains other surprises in
hard ambitous the weak of heart and
those poor with horror should not play
the poor with horror
I guess that's Mays me [ __ ] alright
in addition this game uses some
discriminatory language when some parts
may be taken as oh okay actually like
put this in every one of my videos maybe
it uh okay please play with it advising
in my matters is adorable it's been
three years since my own past due to a
certain turn of events I moved into the
house that had been neglected ever since
her death all this sounds like a horror
scenario that's stock opening whoa
who do I play as Nikita Kimura it's
played sure that's gotten dusty I
suppose it was left for three years take
a look around my house oh I love how you
walk it's adorable so yeah this is not
as polished as thick and apparently but
it's like I said it's supposed to be
scarier so I think that's pretty cool
my makeups sheesh I look terrible
I would never say that it'll be like
[ __ ]
so what am I doing here and what am i
hey guys how you doing what am I
supposed to do here in love huh she
walks maybe I'll just go to bed look
that bad I can chill here look at have a
toilet slippers and sing good and like
walls and won't open oh [ __ ] what is
gone nothing inside not even a futon I
guess she didn't live alone was she
living now why would someone call a
house that's been abandoned there we go
nope oh it is this is tails where is it
Oh Mickey you're there already how's
your new home Mickey very dusty but it's
nice and big I'm not even gonna say it
that's good to hear Oh your luggage
should be arriving tomorrow Thanks um
can I ask something I've been finding
locked doors all around the house do we
have any keys ah keys I don't suppose I
would she had quite the per sec she what
she even locked doors in her house a bit
stupid if you ask me well do what you
can about it I need to ask you answer
that to more people do what you can
about you can call a locksmith
well bye thank you mom
and help [ __ ] sorry bye my mouse yes ah
it's late I'll take a shower and sleep
it's like crook man repeating itself now
I just got to find the [ __ ] bathroom
nail that apparently done anything but
I'm so tired I'll take a shower I can't
relate to that I can totally relate to
that
that's how I should the gift on second
floor I'll sleep after line all right we
go it
go ahead by how you don't get they see
you madam on the [ __ ] was that oh you
scare the [ __ ] out of me
coat rack huh in the coat pocket huh I
don't know where it goes I don't want to
go hunting for it where it fits today
I'll just okay just go to sleep just go
to sleep yes perfect
I don't next I'm not exactly who does it
like sleeping oh and someone else bad
but oh well like who doesn't like
sleeping what is wrong with you it's
like the best thing ever
especially with me sorry Ross are you
making noises what what what the [ __ ] a
dream I can't really remember I forgot
to take my medicine maybe that's why I
woke up
I'm thirsty I'll get some water in the
kitchen I don't like this bras out day
one
oh it's like Paranormal Activity day you
100 nits alright cool
varible what hair what what hair growth
why did this come out I have the water
check tomorrow
I just want to sleep now yeah you just
want to sleep
I'm like [ __ ] that I planned how you're
doing did did I hear something
plan did you say something no no
something here allow what the [ __ ]
I'm sorry okay oh I guess it was nothing
did that door is open I better go in
there then I thought this store didn't
open why is it open now stay out and
then we're gonna save actually yeah can
I even save ya can cool alright let's go
ahead let's just stain could it be
did you pee chair that is disgusting
okay that was fun let's gonna go what
what oh okay
ah that's nice what what go go go there
what is that thing comet Huawei Oh
gross I have to get away it's activate
why should I hide explain fleeing
mechanics okay there was various places
to hide around the house pick up leaves
to hide and hide there before the
monster comes in the room okay
oh the possible hiding spots one is
correct two were deaths and for the
rescue will be fun
okay but I'm also follows you into a
room you cannot hide there [ __ ]
I tried well at least I say so thanks
thanks for that Oh
okay okay I can do this I can do it I'm
so [ __ ]
god you're so fast oh just go just go
just go and have some [ __ ] where